[Musique]
merci Stéphane ravielle de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu des
Bouches-du-Rhône non inscrits au Sénat
des êtres membres de reconquête c'est le
parti d'Éric Zemmour on va évidemment
parler de ce parti dans quelques
instants mais d'abord deux questions
d'actualité on l'a vu dans le journal
Elisabeth borne a rencontré hier les
distributeurs de carburants pour leur
demander de vendre à prix coûtant ce
qu'ils ont accepté 120 000 opérations à
prix coûtant dans 4000 stations jusqu'à
la fin de l'année elle a réussi à mettre
la pression sur les distributeurs
fasse un effort pourquoi pas je crois
qu'elles ont les moyens d'assumer
d'assumer cette charge avec des
conséquences on a entendu aussi sur les
petites stations indépendantes qui elles
sont du coup menacées donc on voit que
le gouvernement ne regarde pas plus loin
que son petit intérêt médiatique ou de
communication parce que il y a quand
même un qui en vendant à prix coûtant
permettrait d'obtenir un litre à 80
centimes d'euros
c'est l'état puisque l'on sait que
environ 60% du prix du litre ce sont des
taxes et bien jamais jamais aucun
gouvernement jamais
ni même celui de dirigé par Elisabeth
borne un remis ce dogme en question des
conséquences sur les finances publiques
notamment puisqu'on est en jour de
présentation du budget il faut encore
creuser une déficit et la dette les
pouvoirs publics ne cesse de blâmer les
Français de les culpabiliser en disant
que ce sont des Gaulois réfractaires qui
font qu'ils se remettent en question qui
s'adapte il y en a qu'un dans ce pays
qui ne se remet jamais en question qui
ne s'adapte jamais c'est l'état de le
faire encore une fois on sait bien que
une augmentation du prix du baril c'est
une aubaine pour pour l'État qui
finalement il trouve un intérêt fiscal
important et bien il doit faire des
efforts pourquoi ce sont toujours les
mêmes là les petites stations les
Français les grandes surfaces sauf un
c'est l'État qui continue permettez-moi
d'utiliser ce terme à se gaver et en
faisant porter la responsabilité sur les
autres je crois que le gouvernement doit
faire
les entreprises et les grandes
entreprises qui portent la
responsabilité plutôt que les dépenses
publiques mais quand les grandes
entreprises font des efforts fiscaux
cela se répercute sur l'emploi c'est en
bout de chaîne ce sera toujours le les
Français qui seront privés
d'augmentation privée d'emploi pendant
que l'État lui continuera à dormir sur
ces sur ces deniers que l'État se
réforme et qu'il fasse des efforts
d'abord lui autre actualité on l'a vu
dans le journal vous avez participé hier
à cette mobilisation transpartisane
devant l'Assemblée nationale en faveur
des Arméniens du voca rabat territoire
cible d'un assaut azerbaïdjanais au delà
du soutien envers les Arméniens que vous
avez tous exprimé hier qu'est-ce que
vous espérez avec cette mobilisation
pas grand chose malheureusement je crois
que nous avons entendu le Président
rotaïeu j'ai entendu le président la
veille lors d'un colloque à l'Assemblée
nationale le président
comment dirais-je de l'assemblée des
affaires et des Affaires étrangères la
commission des affaires étrangères
tout le monde attiré un trait sur larsac
on appelle au carambar sur larsac tout
le monde considère que désormais
laserbaïdjian a pris
un système acte de piraterie envahi le
territoire arménien car l'ARS est un
territoire arménien peuplé d'Arméniens
et tout le monde a tirait un trait après
ce silence assourdissant parce que le
gouvernement dit qu'il soutient les
Arméniens que quand il y a des réunions
au Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU ça a
toujours été à l'initiative de la France
c'est pas difficile de soutenir par la
salive par le verbe mais dans les
actions comment nous fait rien qu'a fait
la France rien qu'a fait la communauté
internationale rien alors il y a madame
vanderleyen qui a fait quelque chose de
la commission la présidente de la
Commission européenne elle a signé des
accords gaziers avec l'Azerbaïdjan
autre actualité Emmanuel Macron était à
Rome hier aux obsèques de l'ancien
président italien Napolitano et à cette
occasion il s'est entretenu entretenu
pardon avec Georgia Meloni pour en
parler on retrouve Laurent marchand
bonjour Laurent merci d'être avec nous
rédacteur en chef délégué aux Affaires
internationales à Ouest-France et
Laurent on s'en doute la crise
migratoire était au coeur de cet
entretien informel
du président
français qui est venu formellement bien
sûr rendre hommage à l'ancien président
italien de Georgio Napolitano Mireille
immédiatement saisi l'occasion pour
avoir un entretien de plus d'une heure
et demie avec Georges Meloni et
essentiellement sur le thème des
migrations en Italie propose un paquet
qui comprendrait en échange et en
conditionnant les aides au pays de la
rive sud de la Méditerranée tout un
système de rapatriement plus rapide et
de quotas d'immigration alors ce plan va
être discuté notamment lors des
prochaines rencontres formelles ou
informelles entre les 27 à Malte à
Grenade et puis au Conseil européen mais
manifestement le geste d'Emmanuel Macron
était de créer un axe avec Jordan et
après une année où la relation
bilatérale a été très tendue entre les
deux elle est au pouvoir depuis un an
maintenant que la situation était tendue
bien sûr il n'osera pas échappé que on
est déjà en campagne électorale pour les
européennes et ce geste de d'Emmanuel
Macron est aussi une façon d'enfoncer un
coin entre Le Pen et Salvini puisque
vous savez que l'un des plus principal
le premier allié de jojameloni au sein
du gouvernement c'est Matteo Salvin et
le leader de la Ligue qui lui sur une
ligne assez radicale et outrancière sur
la question migratoire alors on observe
que les deux alliés n'ont pas la même
ligne en fait genre jamais l'eau n'y
veut négocier trouver des accords avec
des partenaires européens donc avec la
France en l'occurrence sur ce thème
alors que Matteo Salvin est sur une
ligne beaucoup plus radicale comme celle
d'ailleurs de Marine Le Pen ils sont
tout d'ailleurs tous les deux alliés au
Parlement européen de Strasbourg donc
c'était un peu un billet à plusieurs
bandes et aussi un autre thème qui a été
discuté lors de cet échange c'est la
négociation du pacte de stabilité la
renégociation du relancement du pack de
stabilité on sait que la Rome et Paris
on est convergences d'intérêts notamment
vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne
Laurent vous avez une question pour
Stéphane Ravier de même
discute et réchauffe un peu la relation
avec Emmanuel Macron Matteo Salvin est
très alliée de Marine Le Pen sur une
toute autre ligne où vous situez-vous à
reconquête entre le pragmatique de
Georges ou la ligne toujours
souverainiste et antéropéenne de Matteo
Salvin nous situons dans une ligne qui
est la nôtre la ligne de reconquête et
qui veut que
plus aucun étranger et qui plus en
situation irrégulière ne puisse avoir
accès depuis se mettre le pied sur le
sol européen nous considérons que nous
ne pourrons nous ne pourrons pas nous en
sortir seul et qu'une coopération
effectivement avec nos partenaires
européens et ce sera la ligne la plus la
plus performante donc elle a eu raison
de faire appel à l'Europe tu as Mélanie
on en appelant à une je dirais à Frontex
Frontex qui devrait mettre en place un
barrage maritime militaire s'il le faut
et cela passe par une coopération en
Méditerranée avec les Espagnols les
Français les Italiens les Grecs parce
que sinon on en sortira pas si s'il ne
débarque pas en Italie débarqueront en
Grèce une barbe débarque pas en Grèce et
débarquement en France c'est donc une
grâce évidemment à cette à ce trafic
d'être humain qui est organisé par des
passeurs qui sont en liaison directe on
le sait avec des des ONG qui savent le
travail des garde-côte libyens il y a
donc une coopération européenne à mettre
en place dans l'intérêt des Européens de
chaque nation pour faire en sorte que
ces clandestins car ce sont des
clandestins qu'on appelle migrants
aujourd'hui et bien soit bloqué en mer
évidemment
mis en sécurité mais mais je dirais
raccompagner dans leur dans leur port
d'origine parce que parce que on en
sortira pas vous savez qu'en en 2050 et
bien le Nigéria la population du Nigéria
sera plus importante que que la
population européenne donc je dirais que
le torrent et et toujours et chaque
année plus plus puissant si il n'y a pas
de coopération européenne alors ça sera
la fin de l'Europe et donc la semaine
prochaine
aussi ce qu'elle disait qu'elle allait
empêcher les migrants étrangers
d'arrivée résultat il y en a eu
énormément il y en a jamais eu autant
cette année en Italie est-ce que c'est
pas la preuve que votre politique à
l'épreuve du pouvoir elle marche la
pression la pression migratoire est-elle
l'organisation mafieuse est-elle le
contre pouvoir des juges en Italie
est-elle que Madame Meloni ne peut pas
faire ce qu'elle veut vous savez qu'on a
même pas le droit de repousser les les
étrangers lorsque nous les interpellons
et bien moi je crois que je suis même
assez convaincu que lorsque nous aurons
au lendemain des élections européennes
du 9 juin et bien fait basculer la
majorité de cette union européenne à
droite et bien nous pourrons changer les
lois donc vous en êtes à l'Europe mais
en même temps vous respectez pas les
règles européennes les lois européennes
mais il faut changer les lois
européennes permettre à l'Europe de de
se doter de nouvelles lois qui nous
permettront par exemple de pouvoir
refouler les les clandestins ce que nous
ne pouvons pas faire aujourd'hui c'est
que Madame Meloni ne peut pas faire
aujourd'hui donnons-nous les moyens
juridiques légaux à partir du 9 juin
pour changer la donne dans l'intérêt des
Européens
et Laurent une autre question
ce n'est même plus l'intention de gens
jamais là on est le blocus naval dont
elle parlait beaucoup en campagne
électorale il y a un an elles n'en parle
plus et le projet sur lequel elle
travaille le pacte sur lequel elle
travaille prévoit des quotas
d'immigration légale non pas un blocus
une sorte de barrière et de remparts
total en Méditerranée assez illusoire
mais ce sont des quotas c'est un système
vertueux qu'elle essaie de bâtir avec
ses partenaires européens donc on n'est
pas du tout sur le blocage total alors
moi je le seul cercle vertueux auquel
j'en appelle le seul quota auquel
j'appelle moi c'est le quota d'inversion
des flux migratoires un quota de retour
des étrangers dans leur propre pays
alors madame Meloni prendra ses
responsabilités devant les Italiens moi
ce que je sais c'est que dans notre pays
en France il y a 5 millions de chômeurs
près de 10 millions de pauvres que le le
phénomène de l'immigration atteint
aujourd'hui le niveau d'un grand
remplacement que ces conséquences dans
le domaine de l'insécurité et de
l'islamisme du terrorisme du chômage de
la population carcérale et telle que
nous ne pouvons plus envisager autre
chose qu'un quotas de retour des
immigrés dans leur pays d'origine il y a
un texte immigration présenté par le
gouvernement qui devrait arriver au
Sénat des 10 novembre le 6 novembre les
républicains major ici au Sénat font de
la régularisation dans les métiers en
tension une ligne rouge vous les
soutiendrez on sait pas on est dans on
dit ça aujourd'hui mais nous verrons un
nous verrons dans quelques jours
on nous dit du côté du ministère de
l'Intérieur que il faut donc régulariser
les clandestins qui travaillent dans ces
métiers notamment les régulariser
on sait très bien ce que ça veut dire
vous êtes très bien ce que ça veut dire
donc ils seront ils seront régularisés
mais en nous annonce en même temps là il
y a quelques jours la suppression de 150
000 emplois dans le BTP alors on a
besoin de main d'oeuvre on n'a pas
besoin il faudrait savoir donc encore
une fois cette régularisation qui
est une réalité que Monsieur Darmanin a
quand même du mal à cacher qui est
rejeté par les Français et bien
constituera un appel d'air donc vous
soutien vous soutiendrez les
républicains ici au Sénat je demande à
voir il y a des déclarations aujourd'hui
je suis pas convaincu que tout le monde
est sur scène et sur cette ligne on
verra moi ça a toujours été ma ligne et
encore une fois parce que ça sera un
appel d'air 150 000 personnes qui sont
en fait je sais pas combien on sait pas
qui sont dans cette clandestinité ils
feront venir leur famille ça sera un
signal envoyé aux candidats à
l'immigration qu'en France et en Europe
il suffit de mettre un pied pour que et
bien on puisse y rester à vie c'est un
signal extrêmement négatif pour les
Français on va remercier Laurent
marchand merci Laurent d'avoir été avec
nous elle a une de l'ouestrant cette
Agnès Buzyn la crise du covid les vérité
de l'ex-minis de la santé qui sort un
livre aujourd'hui merci beaucoup Laurent
marchande d'avoir été avec nous on va
parler de Marseille et de l'OM secoué
par la crise déclenché par une réunion
houleuse entre dirigeants et supporters
un sénateur des Vosges se saisit de
l'affaire devant une commission
d'enquête parlementaire on voit ça avec
notre journaliste Steve Jordan
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur sénateur bonjour et
Steve depuis une dizaine une dizaine de
jours pardon l'OM connaît des secousses
le Sénat pourrait venir à la rescousse
très jolie lancement
effectivement alors pas sûr que les
Ultra Marseille antonnent dans les
prochains jours dans la prochaine pour
la prochaine rencontre le nom de Gérard
Larcher mais oui effectivement
effectivement les troubles qui touchent
le clap océan intéressent beaucoup ici
au Sénat on va faire un petit rappel
d'effets on va rappeler ces troubles qui
touchent l'OM lundi 18 septembre c'était
la semaine dernière une réunion a été
organisée au centre d'entraînement
Robert Louis Dreyfus d'un côté les
représentants des supporters de l'autre
la direction du club direction qui
aurait été violemment prise à partie
puisque les supporters ont demandé la
démission du président Pablo Longoria
ainsi que trois autres membres du
directoire réunion très houleuse selon
plusieurs participants et qui a conduit
à la démission de l'entraîneur Marcelino
Marcelino qui a dénoncé des menaces
personnelles et physiques
une encentriste des Vosges il est fan de
l'OM il souffre des résultats de son
club il souffre aussi de la mauvaise
image que renvoie actuellement l'OM
écouter le
nous avons été de nombreux élus à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat être
choqués parce qu'il s'est passé à l'OM
et c'est tout simplement que on voudrait
avec certains collègues voir les
mécanismes entre supporters direction
club parce que c'est pas les premiers
incidents qu'il y a eu dans un club
sportif notamment au niveau du football
pour l'image du foot en général pour
l'image du sport commission à laquelle
j'appartiens à la commission des sports
du Sénat c'est vrai que nous serions
intéressés par cette commission
d'enquête commission d'enquête qui si
elle voit le jour pourrait être beaucoup
plus large que le simple cas marseillais
elle concernerait de manière générale
les relations entre les clubs et les
supporters en France faut dire que l'OM
n'est pas un cas isolé depuis le début
du mois de septembre l'Olympique
Lyonnais connaît également de fortes
tensions avec ces supporters monsieur le
sénateur cette commission d'enquête vous
l'appelez de vos vœux elle pourrait être
utile
un peu sérénité du Sénat ferait du le
plus grand bien ce club qui est toujours
en effet en effervescence je sais pas
écouté le d'habitude le linge sale cela
cela en famille mais moi je trouve ça
insupportable c'est le cas de le dire
insupportable qui lie autant de violence
que les supporters certains supporters
certains groupes de supporters se
croient autorisés ça c'est l'héritage un
peu de Bernard tapied d'avoir dans des
temps de de pouvoir à des à des gens qui
paient leurs billets et qui sont là
normalement pour supporter leur équipe
et pas se mêler de tout encore moins
pour être violent dans le dans le verbe
et pas seulement dans le verbe on se
souvient qu'ils avaient envahi le centre
de de formation et d'entraînement de la
Commanderie faire on se permet tout à
partir du moment où on a une carte de
club de supporters à l'OM et c'est tout
à fait insupportable d'autant que les
résultats alors évidemment on n'a pas
nous n'avons pas remporté la Champions
League encore personne d'autre que nous
d'ailleurs depuis
à jamais les premiers et toujours les
seuls et nos résultats nationaux ne sont
pas si mauvais que ça sont qualifiés
pour la Champions League à deux reprises
donc c'est pas si catastrophique que ça
et là on va alors c'est pas la peine de
mettre de l'huile sur le feu sportif
est-ce qu'il faut faire le ménage dans
ces groupes de supporters on pense
notamment alors c'est quoi c'est le nom
c'est Rachid Zeroual qui revient
beaucoup le leader
winners alors il y a un problème ou pas
les il est pas connu pour être un fin
diplôme si vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est plutôt quelqu'un qui a le
verbaux il fut un temps quand il était
au sein de son groupe il a pris de l'âge
comme nous tous il est un petit peu
moins virulent un peu moins présent sur
le terrain mais il y a quelques années
c'était un agité donc il a il a dû
garder cette tradition dans le verre
c'est pas parce que Monsieur zeroa les
présidents sont de son groupe de
supporters depuis des années que ça lui
ça lui donne tous les droits c'est tout
à fait tout à fait inadmissible donc le
la sérénité de revenir et les supporters
doivent supporter et la présidence doit
présider dimanche il y a eu une autre
illustration de débordement
extra-sportif Steve ce sont des champs
parisiens contre l'OM qui sont montés
jusqu'aux oreilles du gouvernement oui
des champs homophobes à l'occasion du
match PSG OM qui était organisé au Parc
des Princes je vous passe les détails
sur les mots qui ont été prononcés ce
qui est certain c'est qu'ils sont
malheureusement trop courants lors des
matchs de foot la ministre des Sports
dit stop elle veut sévir elle a demandé
hier des sanctions individuelles on va
l'écouter
on a mis au point un arsenal juridique
pour combattre ces éléments là ce qui
est important c'est d'avoir des
sanctions individuelles tournées contre
les personnes qui lancent ces champs
depuis les tribunes et moi quand
j'entends que mais au fond ça fait
partie du folklore etc ça me révolte je
me suis ravi vous demandez aussi des
sanctions
quand il y a des supporters qui n'en
font pas preuve d'une grande
intelligence et dans le seul but et de
blesser l'adversaire alors on va
utiliser des insultes sur tel ou tel
sujet je crois que le mieux ça serait de
les laisser
s'époumonner et une fois qu'ils ont qui
n'auront plus d'air dans les poumons
pour sortir leurs insultes qui passeront
à autre chose on leur accorde une
importance qu'ils n'ont pas il y a un
système n'était pas si ce n'était pas
rapporté pardon je pense qu'il passerait
à des champs plus positifs envers leurs
équipes du coup on leur fait de la pub
parce que il y a quatre couillons qui se
croit malin d'insulter à partir de
provoquer
pas ça n'a rien à faire dans un dans une
enceinte sportive du même ailleurs mais
je crois que si on ne leur faisait pas
tant de publicité on pourrait il
passerait à autre chose voilà c'est de
la procédure
il faut il faut leur répondre plutôt par
le mépris merci à tout à l'heure à tout
à l'heure je dirais si on augmente ou
pas les impôts pour les Français ce sera
à suivre dans une demi-heure merci Steve
on va parler de votre partie reconquête
et des sénatoriales Stéphane Ravier
puisque on sait vous venez du
rassemblement national le rassemblement
national qui fait son retour à la
chambre haute 3 sénateurs ont été le
dimanche ou vous en féliciter il vaut
mieux que ça soit trois RN que 3
macronistes ou trois LFI bon ils sont
passées de 2 à 3 en 9 ans
mais écoutez moi je leur ai lancé
puisque vous êtes passé chez reconquête
je leur ai passé un message à eux il y a
d'autres ou LR sincère de droite sincère
qui en ont assez d'un parti qui les mène
plutôt vers la macronie et qui les
éloignent de leur conviction et de leurs
électeurs et surtout de l'intérêt du
pays donc vous avez parlé jusqu'au
comprenne bien vous avez parlé à des
sénateurs LR
j'ai lancé un appel
une sorte de tribune
les invitants à créer un groupe enraciné
ayant pour seul but la défense non pas
de d'un parti d'une ligne partisane de
slogan parisien mais la défense de nos
territoires que ce soit le territoire
bucco Daniel du Pas-de-Calais du Nord la
Seine-et-Marne et autres donc avec vous
les trois sénateurs RN et vous appelez
DLR à vous rejoindre est-ce qu'il y en a
qui vous ont répondu pas encore mais
nous avons encore le temps nous avons
encore le temps vous savez qu'il faut 10
sénateurs pour constituer un groupe ce
qui nous permettrait et bien d'obtenir
des temps de parole plus importants des
moyens plus importants et d'être entendu
par les Français pas par les partis par
les Français et c'est dans cet intérêt
là moi que que je leur tend la main et
on verra qui vous avez répondent d'abord
à l'intérêt d'un territoire général où
vous avez sollicité des sénateurs en
particulier c'est un appel général où
particulier c'est un appel général c'est
certain qu'avec mes collègues RN nous
avons sans doute plus de points communs
que d'autres mais vous avez pris contact
avec déjà vous les trois sénateurs je
les laisse fêter leur victoire et puis
je les féliciterai de vivre
avec eux et avec les autres pourvu
qu'ils soient je dirais doté de cette
intérêt général de sainte intérêts des
territoires qui nous réunit ici au Sénat
moi je m'en sors depuis 2014 ici j'ai
été réélu en 2020 ce n'est pas en raison
de mon étiquette politique ou parce que
je portais le message de ma présidente
de l'époque c'est parce que j'ai porté
ici au Sénat les les demandes les
problèmes et les solutions des des
Bouches-du-Rhône et au-delà des
Bouches-du-Rhône c'est j'espère qu'ils
sont animés de la même démarche on
pourra on pourra travailler ensemble
est-ce que le résultat dimanche c'est
pas la preuve que votre ancien parti
s'implante désormais dans les
territoires est-ce que vous regrettez
pas de l'avoir quitté est-ce que la
dynamique n'est pas de leur côté plutôt
que du vôtre
passer de deux à trois sénateurs c'est
pas non plus c'est pas non plus un
résultat avec
historique départements oui oui Marine
Le Pen avait fait 30 chapitre 37% de
2000 en 2017 elle fait 42 mais c'est
toujours Macron qui est qui est
président là on nous sénatorial ils ont
plus de voix oui ils font plus de voix
mais il y a trois sénateurs sur 348 donc
ce n'est pas encore suffisant d'en
manger je les invite à élargir leur
réflexion et il y a il y a bien
comprendre que sans union il n'y a il
n'y parviendront pas si c'est pour
porter un message partisan en vue de
l'élection
potentielle de Marine Le Pen à la
présidentielle on n'est pas au Sénat
pour ça c'est pour ça le le travail d'un
sénateur le travail d'un sénateur c'est
porter la voix des territoires pas celle
d'un président ou d'une présidente de
parti justement vous appelez à l'Union
mais vous partez séparément aux
européennes puisque Marion maréchal
portera la liste de reconquête est-ce
que c'est pas le meilleur moyen
les élections européennes ce sont les
élections européennes c'est pas
l'élection présidentielle ce sont pas
les législatives alors je sais que du
côté du rassemblement national on veut
battre Macron mais Macron ils seraient
pas candidat à la fois prochaine aux
élections présidentielles et puis chaque
partie qui est arrivé en tête à
l'occasion des dernières élections
européennes que ça soit le RN à deux
reprises les l'UMP avant et le Parti
socialiste en 2005 aucun a gagné la
présidentielle qui a suivi ok donc ce
sont deux élections tout à fait
distinctes et chacun doit partir sous
ses couleurs et c'est ensuite que ça
devient intéressant lorsque vous arrivez
au Parlement européen et que vous êtes
capable de nouer ou pas des alliances
avec des parties de droite européen ce
qui est notre cas nous avons beaucoup de
contacts grâce à Marie en particulier
grâce à Marion maréchal qui elle a des
contacts depuis longtemps avec nos
partenaires futurs européens moi j'ai vu
j'ai accueilli Marion maréchal à
Marseille pour ma rentrée politique à
rentrer le monde partie Marseille
d'abord il y a il y a quelques jours et
j'ai retrouvé des visages du Front
national rassemblement national qu'on
avait pas vu depuis longtemps donc c'est
quoi votre objectif passer la barre des
5% déjà c'est de faire le mieux possible
c'est il y a pas de chiffres non non on
sait que le rassemblement national avait
dit entre 5 et 10 sénateurs et voyez il
y en a eu que trois donc annoncé des
chiffres
ça ça fait peut-être
plaisir aux militants mais nous nous
sommes dans la campagne en tout cas nous
entrons dans la campagne dans
l'organisation de la campagne avec une
tête de liste Marion maréchal qui est
très appréciée dans le sud il vous le
savez a été conseiller région et je l'ai
vu donc à Marseille et j'ai vu des fêtes
des militants qui ça faisait longtemps
que je les avais pas vu donc voilà merci
beaucoup merci merci d'avoir été notre
invité pendant cette première demi-heure